so once you got over that initial six
months what did you start doing
differently that you you just focus more
on the job or found outside interests it
sounds like you were still working a lot
yes yeah so of course that would first a
year the company you know they're
thinking which way is the best way for
LA office and and then maybe going to
the acquiring things or the producing
things and then so that my boss told me
I have two more focus on their producing
things to have a co-production project
the first one year I'm focused on more
acquiring things but they're on the
second year I focused on they're looking
for the co-production project so that's
the reason I found the cathedral culture
have been dangerous project the vendors
and robot bread for the joint
development and that's the the
cathedrals of culture yes and then also
two is wow wow they're teaming up for
sacred the movie I yes yes that's
interesting i looked at the website
that's our soured co-production project
and and then we already had their
certain relationship with wnat before
having the project so we talked about
let's have their co-production project
together may be over around one year and
then they brought that project and we
felt it's really fit us because and they
need agent input as well that project is
introducing their cultural event or
religion really
even based on the calendar summer
solstice yeah yeah and it looks like
there's a lot of user-generated content
where people can submit their own things
as long as I have releases I saw these
these releases on there right so since
Wiles demographic seems to be more 40s
and 50s is a lot of it geared toward
some of the the religion religious
programs it seems like maybe more
spiritual oh no no okay because it was
kind of hard to find the right content
between powwow and divinity and then
that was the right fit so because they
need their agent contents as well agent
events so we we are a co-producer but at
the same time we acted as a Japanese
production company so we sure that the
Japanese religious even and then we
submit that to their wnat so our
production is included their contents
you